thank you all so much for joining today
and welcome back to the data science
hangout happy new year to everyone
i'm so excited to kick off the first one
of 2022 with you all
and to have ian anderson joining us here
for his first time as well
but just to introduce the data science
hangout
for anyone who's joining us for the
first time
the data science hangout is an open
space for the whole data science
community to connect and
chat about data science leadership
questions you're facing
and really just what's going on in the
world of data science
so if you ever want to go back and
re-watch these or some of
the ones that we had in 2021 or share
with someone who's missed it they'll be
recorded and shared up to youtube as
well
we really want this to be a space where
everybody can participate and we want to
hear from everyone so there's a few
different ways you can ask questions
during the session today so you can jump
in live
you can raise your hand on on zoom
put questions in the zoom chat
feel free to put a little star next to
your question too if you want me to read
it out loud otherwise i can just call on
you to introduce yourself and jump in
but we'll also have a slido link to
where you can ask questions anonymously
and
i think tyler will share that in the
chat in just a second here
but without all that i'm so happy to be
joined by my co-host for today ian
anderson
ian's the director of hockey analytics
at the philadelphia flyers
and ian i'd love to start by maybe
having you and jump in and introduce
yourself and share a bit about your team
and the work that you do
uh hello everybody first of all and
thank you for having me um
and uh
i'm also excited to be here and talk
about
all things data science sports flyers
whatever people want to do
basically i've been with the flyers now
since 2014 um had a variety of different
titles or roles i guess over that time
um
i guess i don't know if how deep you
want to get into it or if yeah it was
one of your questions if i'm jumping
ahead but i can expand on on what i've
done started as a kind of team of one uh
i started in 2014 in in hockey as i
don't know
who the participants are today and what
their experience level is with the sport
but i was the third full-time
uh analytics staff member in our sport
hired at that time and then there was a
rash of hirings during the 2014 summer
but now that's widespread across the
sport so um i'm expanding my team
currently we'll be a team of six very
soon um so that's the general overview i
guess for today
that's awesome thank you and
yeah as we're waiting for some questions
to come in from everyone i think that
would be really helpful to expand on how
you kind of started
this small team and how you've grown
over the past few years too
yeah yeah so a little bit of my back
story too was i was working for
the washington capitals in the nhl
in a different role uh starting in
around 2007
from 2007 to 14
i was in more of an operations role
embedded within the team and i just kind
of noticed that we didn't have anybody
at that time during those years like
doing this type of work and it was being
done in other sports um
and i just kind of realized like maybe
this is something we should be doing you
know and i kind of asked they said sure
you you want to do it kind of thing and
i was like well i don't know how
anything about this like technically
speaking right how to code or i didn't
go to school for that that's not what i
did so
another piece all shares i'm a
self-taught programmer i got my master's
through northwestern's
masters of
predictive analytics it was called at
the time i believe they changed the
program since then but there might be
some people on this on this call that
are from that is from that program as
well um
taught myself how to do it and then
again i that led me to the flyer so
that's kind of my backstory but um i
don't know how much more you want to get
into that
that's amazing so you just said hey we
should be doing this and just started to
learn it yourself
yeah i mean i i talked with somebody
and i was like maybe i should go work in
baseball and the person was like wait a
second so there's nobody doing this in
the league there's no
body with skill these skills like why
are you trying to leave like you should
be doing that there it's kind of the
advice i got and i was like you know
what that's a good piece of advice
so i just did some research and back in
2014 there weren't a lot of programs too
that's another thing i wanted to like
share with people is like we're here we
are just started 2022 and one thing
that's amazing to me about this industry
and especially about sports analytics in
general is like it wasn't that long ago
like we all lose track of how fast this
is moving and and eight years is not a
huge amount of time it is in some cases
and in some cases it's not and so to see
kind of how things have expanded and
going through the hiring process now
seeing the applicants and the level of
their skills over the eight year period
is like it's exponential growth you know
so again i'm getting ahead of myself but
i'll leave it at that
i imagine there's a few people on the
call too who might work in industries
that are pretty new to to using data
science and
could possibly be in a similar position
so i'm curious if you have any tips for
going about like starting that program
up or convincing people that you need it
um
yeah i i think what i will say is i have
a lot of experience on this again i came
got dropped into an organization with no
infrastructure no data pipeline no
anything right it was just like here you
go you figure this all out one person
right
and so what you what you realize very
quickly as i'm sure everybody here can
attest to is you can't do this by you
just work by yourself it's a team this
is all done by a team of people
and um anyone that is doing it by
themselves uh my hat goes i tip my app
to you because um it's a lot it's a lot
to be uh knowledgeable across all areas
right so um
i i guess like my piece of advice i give
people because i do have people who talk
to me in various teams and are different
stages of their developing their program
right
and i just tell them like that what has
worked for me is just create creating
like
a very small reproducible example of
work or starting very small with a
project that you can deliver right and
even if it's not the best
the best or what you would consider the
best
just give people something that they can
see and touch and feel right and then
they get to start using or seeing how it
improves their lives like sometimes the
products we make is just making our
co-workers lives easier and
automating some tasks or things like
that right so do something that people
could see that makes their life better
that they enjoy
and and then they say wow this is
awesome great work and then you say okay
you like that like here's where we want
to go next and here's why we need to
expand the team because we could be
doing more in xyz these areas right um
so instead of trying to do like
everything all at once is just like
start with one small thing and then
build on that like
kind of like taking a long-term approach
i guess would be the best
that's super helpful
yeah zach i see you're kicking off the
questions in the chat and i'd love to
turn it over to you to have you ask it
okay so first of all i don't know much
about hockey i've never watched a game
but i do follow the nfl
and i'm sure you're aware that they do
the big data
submissions today
uh which i have submitted to project if
you're interested in saying
but my question more about is i see
that megan
i don't know how to pronounce her last
name which is really bad has a big data
cup in march end of march
and i was wondering if like there was
other
hockey equivalents of the big data where
you can get like
normal uh data that's hidden away from
the public that's available to see what
the public can do with it
yeah this is something i'm extremely
interested in um
keep track of myself obviously
because the tracking data that you see
in the big data bowl that the nfl is
doing
we have uh our league has been working
on the exact same technology for
years and it's finally uh this year so
this october of 2021
was rolled out league wide it's in every
game every team everything in the nhl
now so uh that being said we're
obviously a couple years behind the nfl
but i could see
the nhl potentially doing something
similar here in the next year or two so
i'd be on the lookout for that that
being said there was a big data
cup is what it was called
playing on that same idea run by a
company called stathletes which is a
data provider
to various different hockey leagues um
and they did their first one within the
last few months i i don't remember the
date so i apologize um but within the
last say six months they they did uh
something similar where they released
their um
data that they have their company
produces and they ask people to
create a project similar to the big data
bowl so you guys can google that and
everyone can figure that out themselves
offline
but
again that's year one right they've only
done it one time i imagine they'll
probably try to do it again and it'll
expand and get better so anyone that is
looking to do hockey work similar to big
data bowl the nfl is rolling out it's
coming um i imagine it'll get better and
better so that's my take on it
yeah we're talking about the same thing
yeah megan kind of their co-founders yep
there you go yeah yeah perfect thank you
awesome thank you
ian i see there's an anonymous question
and this has come up in some of the rn
sports analytics conversations too but
the question is sports teams feel like
such an interesting but difficult type
of organization to break into
how do you get into that world and
what's so unique about the industry
oh yeah a great question um
i have a ton of mixed feelings on this
question is
again when i started years and years and
years ago like people always the first
thing they want to ask you which is a
relevant question i understand why
they're asking is like how did you get
in like but the problem i have and it
always makes me cringe answering the
question and trying not to avoid it is
like this is a totally different world
today than what i got into so my story
is so irrelevant now that i if i told
you it's not reproducible you know to
use them to use a data science question
like i can't reproduce what i did
then now it's not possible
um in saying that what what i would the
piece of advice i would offer people
today and the benefit that they have
today is that there are all these great
programs like big data bull big data cup
um okay goals expanding obviously like
there's so many different platforms even
our studio like all the different tools
that have been developed for people to
showcase their work
shiny apps
um you name it right like there's so
table gt table contest like there's so
many ways to build a portfolio today
that there wasn't even a few years ago
um so
it's it's all out there for you to build
your own portfolio and like i said that
this is i'm passionate about this
because i'm literally in the middle of
hiring right now and there's just like
no no excuse not to have a portfolio now
like there's so much you could be doing
so i would just tell people um do the
job you want and that starts now like
you could be doing the job now um
and it's going to require some extra
attention outside of work hours maybe
and things like that but it's all doable
um
so that's
the easiest piece of advice i guess
thank you and to expand on that a bit
more would you mind sharing a little bit
of info on the roles you're hiring for
uh yeah sure
i posted
three different roles
so i'm taking my team now which is
myself
i have a assistant director and he's
like ahead of my back end data
engineering um pipelines and things like
that and i have an analyst on my staff
right now as well we're trying to expand
double the size of our
our team
hiring another quantitative analyst who
oddly enough in this conversation is
likely going to focus a lot of their
time on the player tracking that i just
mentioned that is similar to the big
data bull stuff
and then also another backend
engineer developer
um to work closely with the one that i
currently have because that is growing
in scope right um
and then um
the third position will be tbd it might
be a software developer something front
end i haven't decided yet but that's
what i've
posted as and those are the applications
i'm looking through currently
cool thank you
and and when you just mention like
there's no excuse for someone to not
have a portfolio is is that something
that you like sometimes come across and
actively looking for people or is that
just on resumes that people send
i think it's both you know what i mean
like if you want to take that a step
further and like a lot of people have
done put some of that stuff out in the
public sphere then
people will find it like if it's good
enough people will find it i i we're
always constantly looking and
people love to share good work and
it's amazing the network effects of
twitter and linkedin or whatever it
might be
um you know i was
actively reading a paper i saw on
linkedin from a
connection from years ago who's doing
some work in the bundesliga
soccer right he did something on uh
passing
uh modeling passing efficiency and stuff
like that so i'm like i'm reading that
paper right now like
that could be your paper you know what i
mean i could be reading it right now
that's something that you've done and
some work that you've done or something
in a big data bowl i i
when i have time i try to go through a
lot of those submissions and see what
people are doing what ideas can you
borrow and steal and things like that
and also just see the type of work
people are doing it's the easiest way to
really find good work definitely
robert i see you asked the question you
said i can read out loud um the question
ian was does knowing analytics at the
level of depth that you do impact your
ability to
enjoy watching sports
uh yeah that's a good that's a very good
question the only thing i'll say on that
is um
this is your job right um
and uh i'm passionate about it it's it's
all consuming doing this type of work
obviously it's there's no days off right
kind of because like sports don't stop
right like when you do your nine to five
you go monday through friday but like we
play games saturday sundays holidays you
name it so it has to be something you're
passionate about that's another thing i
tell people like this has to be the
thing you think about constantly i think
about in the shower i think about dinner
i think about it all the time not
because i have to but just it's what i
enjoy right so um you should be doing
what you're passionate about um
but in saying that um i haven't cheered
at a sporting event and i can't even
remember it's just like it's not
ingrained in me anymore to like cheer
even when i go as a fan it's hard to do
thank you
i see there's quite a few other
anonymous questions that are coming in
as well on slido and so just a reminder
if anyone wants to ask questions there
too you can do so anonymously
but one was a repeated theme so far in
any data science discussion has been
automating stuff
any thoughts on why data science teams
do these not the app development team
uh
that's a good question so sorry can you
repeat was there two questions in there
like one about animation and what was
this like can you separate the question
yeah definitely and feel free to jump in
if anyone wants to add more context if
that was your question but it says a
repeated theme has been automating stuff
do you have any thoughts on why
data science teams do these and not the
app development team
that's a bad question for me i guess
working
in the sport being um
in the context of sports like we're like
a startup right we have i i like i just
got done saying it's me and two other
people like we're so small we're all
doing everything so i
i don't even know if i can answer that
question to be honest like i don't have
an app team i wish i did
but i don't we're all kind of helping
each other out and doing things um so
i'm gonna pass on that one only because
i'm not knowledgeable not because i'm
skirting it right
i i don't mind jumping in rebecca or ian
to throw you a bone unlike my opinion
how i've seen it um
it's a very fair question like extremely
fair
and like most things it depends your
context is really really important
from my experience and working in a
couple different sectors
i would group it in a few places one
your typical developers no offense to
anyone on the board please don't jump
through my webcam you don't know data
you know how to program
so those data automation pieces are a
lot of times about automating data and
processes rather than building front-end
widgets and building ui and building
that kind of context they can
how how we're positioning it and how
i've seen in other places those
developers optimize they don't create
that automation process right so it gets
into that refinement piece i see that is
one one area where it happens
in other sectors um again
truth bomb
collective bargaining agreements and
unions so in a lot of organizations i.t
shops or i.t groups are unionized so to
have them jump outside of that role is a
very difficult piece for upper
management and executives to to play in
so i'd see those two types of factors
are really large aspects which puts data
science data analytics teams in a good
position because
we program we collectively we program
and we think about process and we think
about the data in the automation rather
than well i have to have this button it
has to like
ui software development conceptual ideas
i would leave that and then
as
always
thanks ryan i see there's like
a lot of great comments in the chat
around that too and
talking about how
if you want it to happen more quickly a
lot of times the the data science teams
will be the one to do that and alec i
love your comment there my
proof of concept shiny apps have been
alive for two plus years now
yeah uh the one thing i will add on that
though like what i'm trying to get up
trying to build towards with my team now
is a little bit closer to what ryan is
just got done describing which is like
right now i might be doing you know uh
if i'm doing building an app work or
let's just use that because everybody
understands that right um i might be
doing like the data aggregation building
the features things like that and then
i'll be doing the modeling then i'm
doing the validation instead of doing
this then i'm you know uh
deploying the model
on something or designing the app itself
then i'm doing ui like i'm doing all
those components right now and so like
i'm not an expert necessarily uh i might
be an expert in one of those like five
things like a perfect world a high
functioning data science team in my
opinion
um and it's something i would aim to
aspire to be is that my engineers the
two guys that are two people i all have
working in that in that role
like
they're the experts at like feature
engineering and especially when you get
big data scale right like uh making that
data pulling that down and and
manipulating it as efficiently as
possible
because once that loop comes back to
production it's going to have to come
back to them anyways usually right as
new data is feeding in they're going to
be the ones that can optimize that
portion of the process and when i do it
it's probably going to be inefficient
compared to what they can do right um so
that would be like the first step is
having them do it then the modeling is
the second step and then the front end
ui that's a whole different field the
people that have expertise in that so i
would say like what i'm trying to get to
eventually is have all those things be
experts right
thank you ann
um i
i see there are a lot of questions also
going back to what we were talking about
earlier on hiring
and there's a great question that came
in anonymously that was what should
candidates look for
or evaluate when considering a team or
organization to join and if you're
hiring how do you stand out to
candidates
um
i was hoping for this question
because i know hiring is on everybody's
mind and it's been i will admit it's
been years that i've been on the other
side of the table but i've done three
iterations of hiring myself over an
eight year period in in
on my on my team now so i've seen this
evolve and the things i'll say
are honestly
you'd be surprised how many people just
don't
um
take the time to like customize their
resume like if there is some sort of
like prompt like i ask questions and
they don't fill them out or they don't
take time like they don't answer the
questions that i'm asking so i can't
even evaluate you because you're not
doing what i'm asking you to do off the
hop so don't underestimate that part of
that first stage right and then the next
thing i would say is like
really lead with
what you what work you have done that
will be most relevant to the position
your
your um
you're applying to right so i just did
an interview this morning um a second
round technical interview with one of my
candidates
and
she has great experience um
obviously i'm moving her along i think
she can do the work and she drops
something on me and i'm like wait a
second this is nowhere in your
your resume and we've had this is our
second conversation this is super
relevant to the job you're you're trying
to get with me and you've left it
completely off like why and if i didn't
ask the right question i would have
never learned that about her i'm like
okay you need to put this
somewhere very very high if it's not
with me the next person because this is
so crucial you know you almost missed it
and that piece of information you just
gave me like so relevant so that would
be like another piece of advice that i
literally just learned this morning is
like this person was withholding a very
key piece of information
um that
she didn't think you could put you know
to put the highlight and i was just like
man this is
that would have been unfortunate for us
to miss that
um so that would be one and then the
last thing i want to tell people is that
in sports especially i'll only speak to
sports because that's my expertise so i
apologize for people that want industry
but maybe it's true for industry is is
like in 2014 when i started there was a
couple data science programs
and it was like as i've done hiring i
was like
struggling to find people that had
skills right
and now the applicants i'm getting is
everybody has skills because there's so
many great programs
like i just got done describing there's
so many different avenues to showcase
your work
so how do i differentiate those people
now right they used to be like i would
get 100 applicants and five had skills
so now i'm getting 100 applicants and
and 40 have skills
okay so now that gap is like there's
still how do we differentiate amongst
the 40 now should be your question and
the question and then the answers i have
to that are like projects and things
that showcase specific to the our
industry which is sports right show me
something that you could apply there and
then now we're going to get into like
people that have domain knowledge and
that's probably true of industry too is
like how can you develop your domain
knowledge you have all these great
skills you might work in industry but i
i can't draw the parallel from your
industry work to
what you know about hockey now and that
might be as we get down as you get down
to the top three applicants that might
be the differentiator for you
so show me that you understand hockey
right
right
and maisie i see you just asked
a follow-up question there too which i'm
curious as well so feel free to jump in
too if you want to add anything
but maisie i think you were asking
around what was that information that
they left off
yeah yeah like the candidate your
candidate story
yeah
don't i don't want to
uh
you know blow blow that story up but but
it was the point the point i'm trying to
make is that it was
she
was working for another i'll just call
it
organization and she
was
there was a bottleneck in their process
as a team right
and she got tired of it and so she said
i bought an ipad
i
bought a book
i developed an app
a piece of software and i run the
software on a daily basis
sorry about that trevor
there you go and i run the software on a
daily basis and
upkeep in and do all the stuff i'm like
why are you telling me this now like
that should be the very first thing out
of your mouth like that's an amazing
initiative to do like there's so many
things i could go on and on a half an
hour about just that um but like
initiative she taught herself to do
something she developed code and
software executed it start to finish
maintaining it made the organization
better like how is that not the very
first thing you're talking about
i don't know i don't know i'm crazy
maybe i hit real crazy
yeah
thank you
um i think part of that question too is
also
for data science leaders themselves too
how can they also make
the roles more appealing to a candidate
like if somebody has maybe
five roles or more that they're
interviewing for
um
yeah that's another interesting one for
me because i did have some people apply
across my positions
another thing i did want to get across
is now that teams are
when i say teams i mean like
analytics team groups within
the sporting setting they're growing now
right so now it's not um when i started
it was like okay you're hiring one
person and they need to do everything
and now i'm gonna have a team of six so
now i'm looking for people who has like
expertise in a certain area right so
showcase that you have
not just the broad knowledge of all
things which is great right but i also
want to know
if you are joining my my team which i
call like my group
where where are you an expert where do
you make us better like where are you
better than me i want to hire people
smarter than me that's this is my
philosophy is like hire somebody smarter
than me in a different area so that they
can be the expert and tell me what to do
or or take ownership of that piece of
our group right
so showcase that you can become an
expert in something i don't know what
that is that needs to be something you
know the person the applicant decides
um but if a lot of your work is just
like general
that's going to be harder i think as we
move along and and the industry grows
and grows and grows to be a generalist
when we have a lot of people that can do
general things now we need people that
can specialize in something and be
impactful in an area
it's really helpful perspective there
i see there's quite a few other
questions in the chat too and and sep
you just asked one so i'd love to pass
the mic over to you if that's okay
yeah sure hi ian um
new year i think at this point it's like
that right but um but uh yeah i was just
curious about i see that your
progression within the organization is
really kind of you know now your
director of analytics over there you
know what are some some of the
challenges that you find as you kind of
have i guess leveled up and
if you don't mind sharing some of that
upgrade
yeah um again this is like my 2022 um
goal for my myself is like
and i'm being vulnerable and honest here
when i say this is like i started as a
team of one and my prior role i kind of
worked for myself a little bit
independently as well um and then i
hired two people that i have a group of
three and to be honest like i'm learning
the management side of things um
as i'm as i'm going i'm doing it on the
fly kind of thing and i i do believe i
need to get better at
managing a team a data science team so
that's what i'm going to focus on this
year is going how do i go from three to
six people that i that are a part of my
group including myself right
um
how do we organize ourselves and
optimize our group right and that's
something i think um
is what i need to progress at next is if
anybody has good ideas please drop me a
note you know
i'm looking for high performing data
science teams and how to manage them and
make sure everybody
um
is pulling in the same direction and
feels uh empowered to do their job so
does that kind of answer your question
i'm sorry i might have
misunderstood
no that's that's great yeah thanks okay
and we can also make it more of a
discussion too if anyone else wants to
jump in and and have some feedback too
yeah i guess to expand on that step is
just like the the my progression has
been like going from an individual
contributor to now going to like a
manager right and what that entails and
then i'm also part of like a management
team that is doing more strategic type
work and like
um
you know long
short medium and long-term planning like
things like that so it's like
distinguishing those
roles
that's where i get split into is like
it's not just
um the contributing data science work
it's the managerial strategic work as
well
thank you ian
i see there was a question earlier going
back to the idea of the portfolio too
that someone had asked
what is more impressive
to you for portfolios a machine learning
model or exploratory data analysis with
tables plots different visual
storytelling
um
for me i think it's it depends you know
it really depends i've seen people just
do
excellent work in
a variety of different domains so
um
i don't really have a great answer for
that i think it's just really showcasing
like what you are passionate about and
making it clear what
your what sort of impact your work is
going to have like where where do i fit
you on the team right if it's modeling
like here's my modeling work and if i
join your team i'm going to be the
expert in these areas and
here's the domain knowledge i have about
hockey to
apply
that problem to this you know these
tools use these tools to apply to that
problem right so you got to
make show me that you can make that
bridge right is it like the technical
stuff is all great but i also need to
know that you understand how to apply
that to the right problem within the
game of hockey which
you know that being said the game of
hockey is very complicated more so than
almost every sport it's way more
complicated and i can go on about that
but
it takes it takes a lot of domain
knowledge to understand our game so i'm
not saying everybody here needs to be a
former player i'm not a former player i
have no playing background at all i'm
just saying you need to understand all
the components of the game itself to
be able to do the job
for sure and trevor i i see you had a
question you just put into the chat and
i'd i'd love to have you ask that live
and
if it's okay to maybe also ask about
some of the process that you're going
through internally and trying to show
showcase the importance of data science
too
oh happy new year everyone
happy new year happy new year
uh so my question is is a continuous
question right so
as you go up the ladder of moving from
executing day-to-day projects to
actually managing a team
i it's just something that lingers in my
mind because in your current situation
that's how it is but
next year it could be different so i've
always wondered if i move so far away
from the code
so far away from managing actually
executing projects
um do i loot my lose my coded skills and
when i'm in a next environment
where i need
that skill set um
is that going to be a difficult process
to refresh myself you know it's just
something i always
toy with you mentally
if you understand what i'm asking
now um
that is
a great question and i'm actually going
to drop start with everybody i want to
drop a post that i was reading last
night
and the comments right now and
again this is on top of my head so i was
literally reading this you guys can
anyone that wants to read can you guys
all see that everybody i just yes yeah
it's an excellent blog post so you guys
it talks a lot about what your question
was so i'm not skirting it but when
somebody could say it better than you i
tend to just allow the better person to
um say but
but trevor i i will say like i'm
that's what 2022 is going to be for me
is is
sorting out what you said am i moving
further away from the code am i managing
the team am i supporting people in the
sense of creating tools for them to do
their job better maybe that's some of it
um
like whether that be for the our users
out there are we creating more packages
that are more internal packages that
help everybody do things is it just
setting expectations and um
and managing the group through like
processes right like uh get
you know get version control type stuff
is it templating uh all of our workflows
so that it's clear that we're all
working collaboratively but we have a
standard structure right
um
so those are those are the really
relevant questions to building a high
functioning team i think and
we've made strides in that over the last
couple years
i give a lot of credit to
um the two people on my staff for
helping you know to build that because
it's not just me it's we're doing it
collaboratively the the i guess the
piece of advice that i'm trying to
follow is like listen to the people that
are working with me right like what do
you what do they want to see what is
relevant to them like ultimately i have
to have
um some non-negotiables but other than
that like they're doing the work so i
need to check in with them and see what
what makes sense too
yeah so yeah what i really want to find
out um
do we are you nervous about moving away
from
coding
that's what that's kind of what i'm
really going to pinpoint
um
nervous no i mean i think you make times
for things for time for things that are
important to you right we all do that on
our daily basis so so if exercise and
health is important to you you make time
for it you make time for it you just do
right like
it's either important to you or not
right so
if if for me if if coding is something
that i want to continue to maintain i'm
going to do it because i enjoy doing it
i'm going to find the time whether
that's at night when it's in the morning
i have two young kids i mean i'm
juggling a lot of things right so
it's just time management and when you
have a staff it's um you know i've
talked to my with my staff also about
maybe having like
uh toying around with the idea of like
office hours like okay 9 a.m to 12 p.m
i'm like blocked off like i'm that's
where i'm gonna do my my work my
individual work right and everybody's
going to do their individual work and
then 12 to 130 office hours come with
with me to any questions you might have
any things we need we need a decision on
or like there's it's not a clear path we
need to we need to just choose the best
best way to go um so i've played with
some of these ideas again i'm open for
anybody that that has experienced this
and has
great things that they've seen in
practice like i'm all yours i don't i'm
not an expert i'm i'm just a guy trying
to do my best here
okay
all right
excellent thank you when you have a lot
of good ideas you're doing a lot of
great brainstorming the next step for me
this is valerie battaglia i'm a lot of
mediation and facilitation
i would suggest is having a strategic
planning session for some of these and
um it's great because you get buy-in you
get deliverables you have time frames
you get prioritized
um but you're right at that point where
that's kind of what i would recommend if
it's more of a scientific study
and you have a lot of different partners
then it's really getting everybody
where you have a lot of different
expertise
everybody
should learn what
each person's role is and responsibility
and then from there you work on
goals deliverables and
it's really important that you're all
answering the same question when you're
doing data
because if you get
that to me is the crux to quality with
data quality control if you don't know
what your question is you're not going
to get the answer you want so
for scientific studies it's more let's
get everybody on board does everybody
agree this is our question
and how are we going to get there and
what's everybody's role going to be
when it's more management and the team
and what does everybody think is the
priority for the year or more can we
work on
that's more strategic planning session
yeah thank you very much
i i see ryan you have your hand raised
as well
if you wanted to jump in on this topic
yeah if i could just give a little piece
to trevor's question and add on to a bit
of what ian has said in the comments
from frank in there
this was top of mind for me like 12
years ago it's when i really started to
transition from a heavy technical
role into management um
it was geospatial but technical
technical like it kind of doesn't really
matter like if it's engineering if it's
coding if it's whatever right um and i
struggled with it for about two years
and i think it was because i was
comfortable at it right and it's when
you're really comfortable and you're
you're successful or i'm not
anything like that but like when you're
good at something
it's kind of hard to want to leave it
behind
but as as i matured into my role and i
became comfortable of like what does it
mean to be a manager like what does it
mean to lead um
i have a bit of a philosophy that i like
to carry around it's the shield and
spear like my role becomes less of
tactfully putting out widgets it's more
enabling the people to be really
successful so if i try to measure my
success by other people's success i know
that might sound selfish but it helps
rationalize in my head so if i can chop
down and break down all the barriers for
them then they will be more successful
so that means my time right there's only
70 hours in the day so i sacrifice that
technical to enable them to be further
however i think it's still very relevant
to keep your skills at some type of
level just for street cred in your team
bringing new people on having other
people within there if you can talk that
language
and they see you're like oh that's not
just some dude in the suit
the barriers come down and you can not
say that we wear suits anymore but i
don't think anything like it just it
just really helps your team and you can
have those conversations and your
communication goes up in a field that is
technical so i would say do it and i
fully agree if you value it you're going
to make timing like i totally agree with
that
yeah i like to expand upon that too is i
i think
my approach also is to use a little bit
of humility with my team and just go to
them and say like hey
what are you doing here like teach me
some you know like i see you've done
something here like teach me that i want
to learn that like
and i tell people that actively that the
guys on my team right now and people
that i'm interviewing i'm saying i i've
said this briefly earlier and i mean it
like i want to hire people smarter than
me because if you're if i'm hiring
people
like below my skill level all the time
then i'm constantly having to be the
teacher where
i'm lifting i'm trying to lift up uh six
people myself whereas if we hire if i'm
constantly hiring somebody that's an
expert at something above me
then they're lifting me and my group up
the other people right in that in that
one domain and then the next person's
doing that in their domain and so we're
spreading the expertise across and we're
teaching each other and working
collaboratively as a group like the buck
still stops with me and like i'm still
responsible for you know like you said
being the shield as you you said from
management or or moving obstacles out of
their way and sometimes the obstacles
that are in people's way i'd realize is
is like me you know or
or like um
or processes right like like i'm putting
things in their way in terms of like
tasks or making things inefficient for
them to do their job better so how do i
learn to move those things out of the
way right
um so those are kind of things i would
like to add i guess on that
awesome
i love this discussion that that's
happening now so i don't want to jump
away from it but um
ian i i think this kind of answers your
question from earlier ian hunter there's
a lot of ian's on i think
but around
upskilling your team and are you going
to require any continuous learning per
week or per month or specific upskilling
goals per year
um yeah that's a good question i think
um
each case is unique um
but i i don't know about like
i don't know if i personally feel
comfortable like
mandating things i i just don't think um
that ever goes well at any aspect of
life is like mandate things it's much
you want people to want to do that so
again that would to me that would be
like what do you what is that
individual's goal what are they trying
to accomplish what do they want to get
better at and then how can i direct them
or uh put things in their path and say
like hey do you think this would be
helpful for you to achieve your goal are
you aware that this exists right um i'm
a little bit of a unique position
because we work
our organization is owned by comcast
corporation um so we've been integrated
into that corporate environment so we're
still operating as a team but we're also
corporate now employees and so there's
going to be some opportunities now
moving in 2022 and beyond for us to
access some of the corporate environment
where there is a lot of training and
classes and certificates that you can
get through various different uh things
so that's something new that we've never
had and now how can we leverage that how
can
anybody that want i just make i didn't
even make them aware that they can do
that and then provide them the time and
the space to learn right
for sure
it looks like there's a lot of great
suggestions too in the chat around what
other teams do too and
evan if you wouldn't mind jumping in and
sharing that example i think it'd be
really helpful too
here can you hear me yep again okay good
i i gotta apologize to the team i'm on
my work computer and it's government and
so i don't have a web camera on it so
you don't get graced by
uh
the mess that's in the in my office
right now
um but obviously i'm i'm in the
government and so we kind of
uh have to kind of balance meetings
because government nothing gets done
without meetings and red tape uh but as
i was kind of looking through uh
the blog post that you had in there uh
and trying to find a balance between how
do you kind of inform the team uh both
on some professional development kind of
thing so that's kind of i in my post in
there i kind of mentioned we do a brown
bag
which is up to an hour uh and that can
be on
hey i found a new cool way to do
something to hey here's this new
uh
example from like three years ago hey xg
boost is cool and one of our guys that
has spent a lot of time on there uh kind
of went through and kind of did a quick
discussion on that for us uh to uh some
additional work that we were uh that
we've done with some customers actually
was our topic yesterday uh and then in
our case
we do what i call it a project update
and so that's like a quick 30 minutes uh
we've got two time slot or two time
spots a week on there sometimes we use
them sometimes sometimes we don't
and that's kind of a
at all levels of a project you could
just be starting something you're like
hey team
this is what i think the task is this is
who i think the customer is this is the
data i think we need to be using um all
the way to hey
um this is a closeout like we officially
handed this over it is whatever the
the desired end result is it could be an
app it could be a flex dashboard it
could be a report it could be hey the
answer is 42.
um hey this is kind of what we've closed
out here this is what we learned um i in
my position i'm our project management
chief uh and so
my question is then it's like okay cool
so have you documented the code is it
the final
information is on the gitlab page uh
have we closed the loop uh is there
anything else that we need to kind of
circle back on with the customer have we
answered all of the questions um
and more often than not then it's like
oh hey can you from the customer can you
also do this well we probably can but
now we probably need a second project on
here because that's something called
scope creep and
sorry this is a cool project for you but
maybe this team has to pivot to
something else
um so hopefully that was
uh a little insight on kind of how we're
doing things uh to some level
definitely thanks evan
frank i see you raise your hand too yeah
so as everyone was speaking um he had
mentioned meetings uh and it got my mind
thinking and
something really effective that i've
done with my team in the past six months
that i think is probably relevant for
everyone here
every month we've done uh
basically a progress update so there's
an expectation on my team that you have
to be upskilling you have to be learning
i don't care what it is honestly right
do you want to learn javascript you want
python r like whatever it is you just
got to be in that learning mindset
because i think that's when you
uncover like kind of unexpected benefits
of this stuff so every every month we
have an hour-long session i have 12
people on my team now and right if if
you do that math that's not a lot of
time for each person to give an update
it's really quick so each person gets
like four minutes to update everybody
else on what they're doing so they have
to have a pretty concise visual their
story has to be pretty concise
and i found a lot of benefits coming out
of this first of all everyone sees that
everyone else is learning so the
laggards are like oh no i i really got
to get my act together
the other thing is they have to practice
being concise because when you go to
stakeholders to tell a story you don't
have a lot of time or attention right so
they get to practice that
and then
it's probably one of the only meetings
on my calendar through the month where i
see people getting really excited about
it because we have that speed rather
than being on one another one of those
calls where like silence silence
everyone feels a little bit bored it's
like one of those high energy like quick
turnover meetings and we're even like
using that height the the quickness and
trying testing it out with some of our
stakeholders in reverse showcase
meetings so that's been like in terms of
upskilling
one of the the most successful
routines i've put in place
super helpful thank you frank
i'm doing a bad job of managing the
comments in the chat right now i'm sorry
but uh
i just want to go over to
a few other questions earlier from slido
too
and one anonymous one ian was
around the kind of data that you work
with
can you elaborate on different data and
work that you focus on in sports is it
specific to ticket sales player
statistics or free agency money ball
esque
uh i'm sorry i'm sorry can you repeat
that one more time um so it's just the
question was just elaborating more on
the different data and work that you're
focusing on right now so is it more
specific to ticket sales or player
statistics or free agency
yeah yeah that's a good distinction so
um a professional sports team is kind of
split into two business units you have
the business side which is ticketing
market segmentation marketing all that
stuff you guys you know most companies
have right and then where the hockey i
work in the hockey
side of the business which is my boss is
the general manager i work with the
coaching staff scouts you know people on
that side of things um really the
easiest way i tell people what that asks
me you know what exactly do you do it's
like we look for any way to use data you
know to make a better decision so that
could be you know something on the
coaching staff it could be something
with our strength and conditioning group
it could be something with
um
you know drafting players it could be
uh player acquisition it could be
is a player on our team how is he going
to age you know what's his production
going to be like moving forward um so
it's it's kind of endless
it's just anything related to the team
that could potentially make us better or
help us make a
more efficient decision you know add
another piece into that decision-making
process we are not the only piece that
don't i don't want to make that i want
to make that clear um we we are just one
piece of a of a cog right that that
there's scouts involved there's other
um stakeholders that are
all putting in information to one big
piece that ultimately a decision gets
made from
can i ask to expand a bit on that
because you just mentioned there's so
many different pieces so how do you all
work together like how do you work
directly with the scouts
um
i guess it's just being involved in in
the meetings i think we have like
designated meetings right throughout the
year um like next week we have our
midterm amateur scouting meeting um
where the scouts will meet and they'll
just say okay we're halfway through the
season uh heading into this upcoming
2022 draft
what are the players of note who's
trending up who's trending down
um
what are
what which players are we concerned
about which players need more coverage
um from a scouting standpoint it's
always like a it's it's an eyeballs
business right um and
you have to see them to make an
evaluation sometimes a person gets hurt
sometimes they don't play sometimes
they're suspended you know so sometimes
it's like which
guys do we need to go
get more on um so those meetings being a
part of the it's helpful for me i don't
necessarily contribute much to them i
can at times but what i why it's
important and relevant to my role is
that i need to know what the scouts are
saying and what they're interested in
and what their problems are you know i'm
really having a hard time on this guy he
got hurt last year as a 16 year old so
we don't have any book on him
he's
playing as a 17 year old in this league
with these players
and he's struggling with that decision
as a scout
so what i can do as a data analyst is be
go to him after the fact and say hey if
i could provide some information on
similar players doing similar things at
similar times in that league would that
be helpful yeah man that would be
awesome can you get that to me i can
help them in that manner right so that's
where the collaboration is and a lot of
times it's
i think the consulting aspect like some
consultants that are probably on this
call is is this like listening like what
are people talking about what are the
issues right
and then
using my knowledge of the data we have
within our possession is where can i go
to that archive and pull that piece of
information down package it up and get
it back to them so they can feel more
comfortable in their evaluation
is that helpful i uh sorry no that that
is really helpful
when you say package that up to them
how do you share that with them
um it could be a variety of ways
sometimes it's a phone call sometimes
it's a text message um sometimes it's
a report sometimes it's
um
you know a lot of
when i talk with my staff and i'm
interviewing people like a lot of times
a lot of our job is preparing for
meetings if that makes sense um so we
get in these meetings right and
all of a sudden somebody's questioning
okay should we acquire this guy or do we
want to make this trade or uh what do we
think about this player
we need to answer that question right
then and there what sort of tools can we
build prior to
to enable us to answer those questions
at least as best we can in that moment
so a lot of the work is like preparing
so that might be an app that might be a
dashboard that might be part of a web
our website that we have it might be
something like that
but
you might be working three months three
months three months like why am i doing
this nobody's looking at it and then we
get into a meeting and somebody's asking
a question you're like oh i i've been
building that here it is we put it up
and everybody's looking at it and we're
interacting with it so for us it's i had
this
mistake originally thinking that like
i'd be in a position where i could just
give this tool to people and oftentimes
they don't want they don't want to do
that right they just want to see it they
want to see you the expert kind of work
through it and showcase all the
different aspects of the information to
them and sometimes explain it to them
what they're looking at and then they
say oh that makes a ton of sense and
then they have questions on that and you
can work through those so it's just
opening up that box and having more
productive conversations
because if everybody remembers like back
in the old the old days
you know somebody would answer ask a
question right and then you'd say oh i
could answer that
let me get back to you in a week
right like so how valuable is that to
that person they've forgotten the
question a week later
they have or they've moved on or
whatever right we want to answer that in
the moment is the best way to describe a
lot of what we do also
thank you i appreciate that perspective
too and it
it's important to think like i guess in
my head i'm like oh people just want to
create this dashboard or this like
application and just give them that and
that's the answer but
that's not really how it always works
i'm going through just to see which
questions i had missed from earlier um
but bruno i know you had a question
towards the beginning
around
like data and marketing as well and
asking if
gritty was the result of this
do you want to jump in bruno
yeah sure so
greedy jump from the hockey mascot scene
and basically destroy every other mascot
so did you have any hand
into like crafting this piece of
marketing flyers
propaganda
using data or social media analysis or
no that is the brainchild of some
someone else um
unfortunately but um it's amazing how
how he's
taking on this whole life it's at some
point someone will write a book about it
i'm sure let's just i'll leave it at
that and
it'll be uh i'm sure people will be
reading about it in case studies and
harvest business review or something at
some point um
and i'll be reading it too because i
have no idea what went into that and i'd
be interested to hear that as well so i
have the same interest as you
thanks bruno
mike smith i see you had asked the
question earlier as well around
if it's any easier to influence
decisions in sports rather than or
harder compared to other organizations
would you want to jump in mike with your
perspective there
no go ahead that's that's great
i'm just interested to know if you know
it
you're
i guess all organizations you're trying
to influence up to managers
and
you know managers are either
you know going to accept the data driven
analytics or
go with gut feel
but just if if you have any experience
of differences between doing that in a
sports context versus any other
yeah um
i i can't really speak to like outside
of the sporting world because i
admittedly i don't have a lot of
industry experience outside of this
world that i'm in but what i've arrived
at as my own mental model is like people
are people this is like still a people's
business you're still interacting with
team members so
whether you're into sports or you work
at target or walmart or whatever fortune
500 company
the people are still have the same
motivations they still have the same um
personality traits right um
so i i don't know if it's easier or
harder i think it's just people right
like it's it's teamwork it's getting
people um
making people
in the group feel like they're heard and
that their input is is uh valued even
when that decision might go against what
you're recommending it doesn't mean it's
not valued
sometimes it's on the contrary right um
but in sports is there's also an element
of like
there are things and and i would put
this out to all the modelers right let's
make this about data science okay when
we build a model what does everybody
know is that we have
things that are in the model so there's
like the known knowns and there's the
known unknowns so there's things that we
know exist but they're not in the model
right and no model accounts for
everything so
um when somebody's making a decision
um
about
some
with
how i say they make a decision that is
influenced by something else over here
um
sometimes it's not in the model and i
know it's not in the model so like
what would that be like somebody might
be saying what is he even talking about
right so something like that might be
saying hey here's this player um we want
to acquire him he has all these great
results he's going to project out nicely
and then my gm goes down and gets the
guy's medical file from the team that
he's currently playing on and he has
some sort of degenerative issue and that
there's a high likelihood that this
person's gonna
have
health problems you know and that might
affect his performance so like that's
not in my model that's not in my report
that's not in my evaluation that's not
in anything i'm saying it's a known
unknown and when you come to me and say
hey we're worried about this i'm not
upset about that i'm like ah i didn't
know i don't have that information
otherwise i can model it right
um so
there's an element of that like what are
the known unknowns and being okay with
that right
i realize an hour just went by very
quickly so i just want to be conscious
of your time if you had to jump to
right to another meeting okay i'm okay
if you guys want to if everybody wants
to keep going it's fine otherwise i'm
probably tired of hearing me talk
no no there's a lot of other other
questions thank you
um
one question that um
came up earlier i just want to make sure
to ask was around like what does a
technical interview look like for your
team or how do you approach interviews
yeah um
so we've
i've tried to do different iterations on
this but the one i'm i'm currently using
right now and again this is evolving
over time and i'm sure there's better
ways to do it like
my personal opinion is like hiring is so
difficult that's
i don't think any of us are trained in
that i don't know if there is training
so we're all doing our best in a
complicated process
um
but for me what i would what i boil it
down to is like can you do what you say
you can do right i need to have some
sort of test that shows me that you can
do what you say you can do
so it doesn't need to be any more
complicated or
[Music]
intensive than that and i'll give you
i'll give everybody an example so not
this time but last time i hired i got to
a second interview with a group of
people and i had a coding challenge that
i gave people
uh i don't know 24 or 36 hours or
something to do return it back to me and
there's a variety of reasons why i do
that
i got down to the time i was supposed to
speak with this individual and he the
person sent me an email one hour in
advance and just said i have nothing
i could not do the exercise i told you i
could do x y z and either i
overestimated myself or i
you know he didn't say he was lying but
he he basically couldn't do what he said
he could do so i avoided a very large
and costly mistake
um had i gone on to just trust that
person and i'm not saying it was done
intentionally or that this person was
trying to fool me but i'm just saying we
have to have some sort of checks and
balance that people could do what they
say they can do right
and then i just want to see the depth of
of
uh your work like how far do you take
things down are you just a simple
add two numbers together that you know
that's fine we'll get to that in a
second
but do can you show me some techniques
that um i think that you could bring to
the table right and then the third
component of that is
there's no perfect candidate and
everybody's going to come in with their
different strengths and weaknesses right
and by doing this coding challenge
i'm learning about you as a candidate to
say where do i need to upskill this
person where do i need to spend time
with this person on day one prior to
this person starting i'm going to have a
plan i'm going to say this person needs
to get better at xyz or after a certain
number of months i want to circle back
with them and say hey
i think you can utilize these skills a
little bit better and make you more
efficient or
can uh excel your code writing ability
or whatever it might be
or maybe it's somebody on my team like
hey this person on my team i think would
really help you in this area
so by showing me a little bit about what
you can do that's not to eliminate you
as a candidate it's more or less to see
what are your strengths what are your
weaknesses how can i help you how can i
upscale you eventually
definitely thank you and that's that's
really helpful
so i know that
comes up quite a bit in terms of like
technical interviews and sometimes when
people are asking maybe far too much of
of someone versus just needing to make
sure that
they have that component
yeah i'd read the you know the tech
world is inventory to whiteboarding and
all that stuff and putting people aside
i don't yeah i don't think that's um for
me
coming from a sport background
the the whole idea of practice in sport
is to
um
is to simulate
things that you will see in a game
because that's your job to play games so
if we expect you to perform at a high
level in a game we need to simulate that
situation slow it down um help you
practice and get better and get the
synapses moving quickly and firing
quickly right that's the whole idea of
practice just to slow things down and
then gradually build up and up and up
and and translate exactly what you
didn't practice into a game if i'm
having you do something in practice that
you're not doing in the game
why is that relevant why should we be
spending our time doing that so i kind
of see
[Music]
the idea of making somebody code
something on a whiteboard while i see
some benefits to it
what at what point in the game in this
game is you working on my team are you
ever going to stand in front of a white
board and do something like that that's
just not how we work so why would i make
somebody do that
just just one man's opinion yeah another
people that are going to argue this
still to death but just one person no i
i like that
thank you
yeah
but insane agreeing in the chats too
yeah but in saying that when i do give
them a coding challenge i do put them on
our time limit and i do tell them it's
coming ahead of time because that is the
job it's not me being
not
me not being um
fair to them or
putting them under pressure for just for
my own fun
that's not it the job is on it's friday
night and our we're playing saturday and
our coach says hey i'm struggling with
lineup combination or some problem he
might have right um i'm wondering who
should be going this person's hurt like
i'm struggling on who i should put in or
uh line of decision right can what can
you give me on that
i have 12 hours to get him that
information the best of my ability right
so that is the job so i have to put
people also under that pressure of like
saying okay i need to work through this
problem i need to come to a minimal
viable product to give this person that
can give them information quickly
because sometimes we are put under the
gun in terms of getting somebody
something before a game there is a
deadline
that might be different than like
industry where we're working on quarters
or long projects and things like that no
we play tomorrow so i need this before
the game right like
so yeah it's definitely and
so i
i appreciate how over the past few
months this has really started to
feel like a community of people who and
seeing people come every week is awesome
too and
trevor and i know you and i were kind of
just chatting
earlier today um oh i think you said you
have to leave but
trevor you were talking a little bit
about um
how to present to your team on the
benefits of data science and maybe
learning from someone else in the
community who has shown this
to their own executive leadership
um and i just wanted to see if you
wanted to pose that question to the
group before you run
yeah so
just just to let you guys know what
is happening on my side
so we are in the process of
building out a company-wide dashboard
so i'm in jamaica so we call the
dashboard jamaica 360.
uh as in 360 degrees because the idea is
to
give users the ability to see the entire
business
instead of looking at
just their side of the business because
that leads to silos and we actually see
that impacting the results that we get
in a negative way
right so
that's one two
what we're trying to do
is democratize information our data
because what we want to do right now is
to ensure that everybody is data
literate and that everyone can analyze
their own information to an extent
because what we have now is a bottleneck
where
when people need data they have to come
to my unit
and of course that is inefficient it
slows down data slows down decision
making process so we're trying to do is
upskilling the entire organization
and also
um
help people in terms of consuming their
own data the fortunate thing for me is
that which is not typical with data
processes necessarily is that i sit on
the ceiling management team so
all i need to do is to convince the the
general manager and i and and
she's definitely on board in terms of
where we need to go
but um
the the what your thoughts what i would
really welcome is your thoughts in terms
of how best to do it
i've been reading a lot in terms of what
we need to do and some ways of
democratizing information some ways of
sharing information
so any thoughts on that would be welcome
is that a question for me i'm sorry or
is that to the group he's in the entire
group actually
that would regret
i'll jump in a little bit um
i had that problem at a previous role
because uh our audience was the city of
toronto so three million people plus
around the world and i was leading the
open data team
so how do you upscale citizens
to use data to be able to do
transparency and things like that right
now and i talked a little bit about
before to other people
it's a fast forward so you don't have to
go through that painful conversation is
we decided to make it easy for people
based on where they work
so rather than trying to force people to
speak our language i either data science
language be like machine learning
engineer all that kind of stuff
let's not be elitist and say well you
can't work in excel
you can't work there you have to come to
us no no
if it's all about people making
decisions and and not just crediting
their domain knowledge that they bring
to the table we'll let them work
wherever they want don't tell me how to
work i won't tell you how to work so
what we did is we started to make uh
data access that being the raw material
that being the gold so to speak easy for
anyone no matter where they were so we
made
tool sets plugins for really simple
things that most people used in our
which would be our customers education
people and google sheets so they could
access all the data that we had by a
google sheet plugin we made in our
package for our our our package people
made
python libraries for our python users
and we made a plug-in for geospatial
users in open source so so one thing
that we did about that was
making it easy for people to get it
because what we heard from hundreds of
people is i'm not a data scientist i
don't have a stats degree i don't even
know what a csv is so if i don't know
what that is the barrier of entry is
might as well be a billion dollars
they just can't do it's too scary so if
we make it easier for them that was one
way to get them up the ladder and then
we heavily invested in writing and
writing blog stories that were fun
now i air quote fun it's not disney and
pixar fun but like not being like a phd
thesis right it's not being jargon and
taking that away taking that burden cost
away making it so that the entry level
for them was easier and and doing like
using fun words analogies connecting it
to stuff uh swearing with
symbols instead of letters so like
you're just stuff like that so i think
it really boils down to like knowing our
audience and and
having empathy for them
thank you
yeah i'll i'll jump on ryan zendeman
there one thing that translates what
what he said to uh he was talking about
uh data science to
uh citizens i guess or less data uh
sophisticated people right is like using
their terminology right and so like in
sports the one thing that we try to do
also is
by being a part of those meetings with
the scouts and with the uh coaching
staff at times is like what are the
terms that they are using for certain
things right like i might have a metric
or something that we've developed over
here um but if i can't if it's as simple
as just putting it in a language that
they're already speaking instead of me
having to teach them a new language
isn't that like an easy
solution to
um
we all talk about like buy-in and
getting people sometimes it's just we
create in our we meaning like the data
professionals we create an artificial
barrier an unnecessary artificial
barrier between us and the end user and
then we
blame them sometimes for for not meeting
us right where um i think the easy
solution is is like understanding and
being uh aware that that could happen
and try to head that off ahead of time
and say like can we put this in their
words so that
they'll instantly get it they'll pick it
up a lot quicker right and sometimes
just changing that terminology is really
the key to
getting quote buy-in or people to
understand it right
thank
you i love that i know we're
we're quite a bit over on time now um so
i just want to ask one last question if
that's okay
um so you shared that awesome blog post
which i realized was from alex gold from
the r studio team as well i kind of
forgot i forgot it was too i was not uh
plugging our studio no i appreciate it
because i didn't see it now i have to
reach out to alex about that but um
i i was just curious are there other
resources or if it's books or podcasts
or things that you'd recommend to us all
um
there's a few
um
you can send them to me later too and i
can include them in the recording as
well yeah yeah there's there's a
a couple but um i i'm kind of blanking
on the whole list right now i'm like
yeah no it is
um but yeah i'll put a couple in there
um if people want to get more involved
there's obviously a lot of like great
work in the public domain too it's
amazing the work people do again
showcasing their skills or um doing blog
posts kind of things like ryan was
talking about is just show how data can
be fun and how can it be useful and
things like that like showcase your
thinking too like that stuff is
interesting for people to see um
[Music]
and those are obviously like i said the
missing components right when you get
down and everybody has skills what's
going to differentiate people right
definitely
well thank you so much ian for for
chatting with us and if people ever have
follow-up questions or just want to
connect with you is is linkedin the best
place
sure yeah you could do that i think i
have all my stuff on there um you know
the more another piece of advice too for
maybe the younger people on on this call
is like
um if you're gonna reach out to somebody
just be
direct about what you're asking like
sometimes i can't figure out even what
people contact me and i just move past
it because i don't i don't know what
they're asking instead of going back and
forth six times about figuring out what
they want or what their question is
take some time to think about what
you're asking like be direct
be clear and then i can answer you
quickly right um because i don't have
you might think you're one person
emailing why isn't this person
responding but if i get a hundred of
them
it's hard to
get back to 100 people so the more
direct you could be the quicker i can
get back to you and you could be one of
the ones out of those 100 that i
actually can
try to help i do want to help trust me i
do but i need to know how and without
having to weed through
innuendo i guess
for sure that's that's really important
too especially as you get i'm sure you
get a lot of messages on on linkedin too
yeah please no stopping chats please
know can do you have 10 minutes because
again it's 10 minutes and that's not a
lot of my time it's not but if i get 100
10 minutes
that adds up
you know so uh it might be better just
ask one simple question that you want to
know right and then if that's something
that you that you prefer to do i can
help that in that way but um outside of
that it's a it's just
a time situation you know yeah
and sorry one other thing is i was
actually going to repost some of the job
postings and i think i maybe have old
links or it says they're no longer up
yeah yeah i'm
down
down the rabbit hole all right okay and
that's so they've i've turned them off
just because it gets overwhelming um you
know i haven't hired anybody so if you
are really adamant and you want to
insert yourself um
i'll make a
pop culture
uh
reference here my wife sometimes watches
the bachelor right and you know like
their
10 shows in and they introduce somebody
like
i think i always think that's a terrible
idea for that show but if you want to be
that person that comes on mid-show
send me an email
or linkedin
yeah yes
alright well thank you so much ian for
chatting with us i really appreciate it
and good luck today i know or i think
you have a game
yeah we do yeah thank you very much i
appreciate it